hi my name is Luigi Andrea I work at
Wolfram research and today I'm going to
be talking about building maintainable
dynamic interfaces I'm going to take
some of the lessons that we learned
building manipulate and other built-in
interfaces and show the structures that
we use and the best practices that we've
used that we've learned from them
think this notebook is available on the
conference website already will continue
to be available on conference website
after today there are going to be a few
sections in this notebook marked as
bonus which I am NOT going to open
during this talk those are for you when
you get back to your home base to review
at your leisure that dig a little bit
more deeply into some of the issues that
I will be shining a light on today and
this is very much a sort of nitty gritty
code based talk this is not arm-waving
there's gonna be lots and lots of code
samples and I see the door shut so I'm
gonna take that as my cue hi my name is
Lou Deandra I work at Wolfram research
and I was around when manipulate was
born and when a few of the other
interface things were born in version 6
this talk is going to be going to
illustrate some of the best practices we
discovered while doing that while
building manipulate and since then while
building similar interfaces my thinking
is that you in your wisdom will want to
go off and build your own in manipulate
like functions functions that generate
an interface on demand and perhaps you
have already climbed the mountain of
dynamics you've understood manipulate as
a consumer and that's great if you
haven't there are some fine resources
available linked from this notebook
which you should go get from the
conference website if you haven't
already and consider this a sort of a
300 level course in building interfaces
we're gonna be focused very minutely on
a couple of interesting details that I
think will go a long way to making your
interfaces more maintainable and more
long-lived and feel free to stop me as I
go if you have questions if you have
very very detailed questions I'm happy
to stick around after this talk I know
that this is one of the final talks in
the conference and it's I'm competing
with I think a couple of other people
and Poppa Dells when we're done so I
think I could hold my own if people
wanted to chat with me afterwards
feel free so a principle of programmatic
generation we outlined some principles
of dynamic a few years back and
every interface should be generated by a
program there are kind of two
classifications that I put these under
one is you you generate an interface
once and then you store the results and
then users just use the thing that
you've stored so pallets are a good
example of this we use this a lot in
house for things like dialog boxes I'm
not going to be talking about this class
of things I'm not going to be talking
out about interfaces that live by
themselves in a dedicated file rather
I'm going to be looking at interfaces
that are generated as part of your
input-output repple cycle in a notebook
front-end so you have a manipulated
input you get a manipulate output what
should that output look like what should
the boxes of that output look like in
order to have an interface that's easily
maintained easily updated can stand the
test of time and here I've listed a
handful of interfaces that we have an
output in various functions from various
functions and many of them use exactly
the techniques that I'm going to be
displaying here today okay so what's the
big deal why don't we just say well we
have a bunch of interface constructs we
have layout constructs in the front end
we have controls we have this
beautifully robust and deep notion of
variable values and variables that
change and trigger other things that
should update so we have column and
slider so this is this is a nice sort of
first low level approximation of
manipulate and if we were to take a look
at the boxes which I assume all of you
know how to do because you're in this
300 level class we see a grid box and a
slider box so we're taking some of the
information about this interface and
burning the details into the notebook
itself right these boxes exist in the
notebook if we save the file there in
the notebook file we can never change
automatically change that slider to
manipulator for instance that had
animation controls in addition to the
continuous control and in the case of
manipulate of course is not just a
slider and a dynamic display it's also
localization it's also beautification in
various ways
styling and whatnot and so here we have
a say first level second level
simulation of manipulate and the boxes
correspondingly are quite a bit longer
as you might expect because we've got
quite a bit more box generators in the
input well is this a good thing or a bad
thing well we've we've built up more
features in this output but we've also
paid a price of that and if we go all
the way to the end of what manipulate
would have been if we went this route
this is not manipulate but if we were to
have gone this route manipulate as a
whole would have been hey pages and
pages and pages and pages of boxes and
all of these boxes burned into notebooks
for every manipulate output is this a
good thing or a bad thing well it's bad
in a couple of ways one is it makes your
notebooks really big even though they
don't need to be a lot of the stuff from
one manipulate to the next is common the
layout functions are common it also
locks us in for that particular
manipulate output it locks us into a
specific rendering if we choose at some
point in the future to make manipulators
look different or have the arrangement
of the boxes and manipulate look
different these the the boxes that we've
already burned in four previous outputs
would all have to be thrown away and
regenerated and it also locks so it's
not just the graphic design that's
locked in it's also the implementation
that's locked in so if there was some
subtle bug in the dynamic that we're
spinning into these notebooks you know
how do we fix those well again you'd
have to throw away all existing outputs
and start over
so for the demonstration site for
instance which has how many thousands of
uses of manipulate at this point that
would be a significant chunk of
researches time and I'm sure many of you
have dozens if not hundreds of
manipulates be a significant mal use of
your time but luckily we avoided all
these things and we can do better and we
did do better so the goals that we
decided on during the version six cycle
was to only store what's absolutely
necessary to display the interface in
the notebook we only store the bare
minimum that's so
and everything else we attempt to use
the dynamic mechanism to recreate the
rest of the interface from the state
that we have stored the the look of
things should be responsive to the users
environment so if there's options and
such that the user has set those should
automatically somehow flow in you know
they change this the the font family of
output cells that should automatically
flow into the output family that the
font family that's used in in manipulate
we also wanted to make sure that once
you generate a manipulate that would
continue working as well as it can for
the lifetime of that cell or that
notebook file or you I suppose and if
you have new if we decide in the future
that we want to add some new features to
manipulate that cannot be rendered say
on an older front end because we
introduced some new control we
introduced some new box we wanted to
have a nice way some nice backward
compatibility shims so that if you tried
to open these newer notebook constructs
in an older front end yes you wouldn't
see the newer constructs in the older
front end but you also wouldn't just see
random pink boxes and random failures
you would see kind of a nice neat fail
condition so these were the these were
the goals and I want to dig into several
of these as we go but first let's get
our bearings about what we I showed what
we didn't do for manipulate now I want
to show you what we did do so for
manipulate the box structure which we
will look at now is a little more than a
page in this extreme magnification 200%
magnification it's still a little more
than a page of stuff and what is the
stuff whoa there's a dynamic module box
which is the way that we store we
serialize things there's a bunch of
state that we're preserving in that
dynamic module box among you know the
important things here are the local
value of the value of the local variable
the current value of the local variable
the current value of whether someone has
chosen to hide the controls in that
little plus icon
they can hide controls the list of
bookmarks that they either added in the
input or interactively added while in
our and wall while using the manipulate
and so on so there's a set of there's a
set of state information that didn't
exist that doesn't exist anywhere other
than in this cell so this cell needs to
remember it but the actual display of
the manipulate well that's if there's a
function that creates that given the
values of all these variables there's a
function that creates the manipulate the
look of the manipulate and in order to
create this these boxes at render time
we merely need to call this function
from inside of a dynamic so this
function that generates the boxes had we
not wrapped it in dynamic this would
have expanded out and we would have seen
panel box and grid box and all manner of
other boxes notice there is no panel box
or grid box or for that matter even row
boxes anywhere in this box structure
those are all hidden through the
indirection of a dynamic call to a
utility that actually builds the
interface boxes and that's the majority
of what's in this dynamic module so it's
dynamic module box some state and a
dynamic call to the function that builds
the interface this is the pattern let's
look at some other examples so interval
slider and another example of control of
a thing that was built entirely in top
level those of you they don't haven't
seen in purple slider before I think
it's I don't need to explain what it's
doing
maybe I'll explain how it's doing this
so this is a locator pane and the Brett
the bar and the slider is a rounded end
line with a an edge form applied to it
these guys are inset images but if you
were to look at the boxes for this
slider you wouldn't see any of that you
would see this is just a dynamic call to
a function that builds the interface
we're not burning any of the details of
this into the notebook so in this case
we don't even need any extra state
information all of the state information
is well where should
the thumbs be and where should the
thumbs be isn't a a question that needs
to be answered by the interface it's a
question that's answered by the value of
the users variable so that's in the user
space everything else can be can be
deduced from this function so we have a
dynamic call to a function that creates
the interface and I'll mention one other
example I have these outputs stored in
the notebook in case the network was
flaky so here is an audio you know we
have a two-minute body of audio here
which I won't even try to play I suppose
but you would expect two minutes of
audio data that takes up quite a bit of
space so how much how many bytes is this
one output contributing to the size of
my notebook oh and I said I wasn't going
to evaluate that but I did well let's
see that's it again at this high
magnification this is what a page and a
half of stuff and looking slightly more
closely we see dynamic module of some
state information one of the pieces of
state information is a pointer to the
URL where the audio actually lives and
then a dynamic call to a function that
builds the interface okay
you're probably sick of hearing me say
that but right now here's the first of
your bonus content again I'm not gonna
be opening any bonus content during this
talk please get this notebook take it
home take a look at it but overall view
here we have if they're state
information that you need dynamic module
to say the state and then a dynamic call
to a kernel function that creates the
interface and there might be some other
things like the initialization
initialization if you need and I'll talk
a little bit more about about
initializing stuff in just a minute any
state information that needs to be
stored should be in the dynamic modules
first argument anything in the dynamic
modules second argument should probably
just be a dynamic call to that utility
function and you're not burning the
details of this into the notebook you
want to keep all of this nice and
modular so that if you decide to change
your definition of that utility function
that displays the interface
you're users don't need to do anything
other than install your new code to see
the results in there and their new that
and their old outputs and you've also
seen in the case of manipulated and
others that there might be a layer
around the dynamic module a tag box
interpretation box something like this
this is so that the interfaces can be
used not only as output but you can
reuse the interface itself as an input
so tag box and interpretation box are
two ways that that you might get your
hands on the thing that's that that the
thing that is getting sent back to the
kernel when you evaluate one of these
interfaces and that's important for us
it may or may not be important for
interfaces that you build okay so that's
the high-level stuff and now I want to
dig into some of the lower-level bits
including common errors that people make
when they first start following these
kinds of patterns how to make sure that
your code is loaded how to give your
user a nice experience when your code is
being loaded how to communicate with the
global scope between the global and
local scopes and so on okay so first
common mistake how does one make sure
that the values of variables if you're
using this utility function you want not
just a value of the variable to be
passed to the utility but you want to
know what the variable is you want to
have your hands on the variable itself
not just its value so here I'm following
the pattern that I just laid out I have
this brand new my interface function
that I'm really proud of and it's
dynamic module of some state and a
dynamic call to a function that displays
an interface okay great what is that
interface well that interface in this
case is just a pair of sliders it's a
slider for local variable that the user
doesn't know anything about necessarily
and a slider for the global variables
they passed in and here's an example of
it so I evaluate this and I'm so excited
and I try to drag these around and
nothing happens well why is nothing
happening because when I pass the value
when I
a invar through to this function this
function did nothing to prevent those
variables from evaluating to their
values so what display actually got here
was not the variable a it was the value
0 and var got looked like the value
point six nine six I must have had a var
somewhere in my session so a slider of
dynamic of zero is obviously not going
to in fact if we had shown the messages
window yeah we would have seen I guess
that's if you can see those but it's
it's telling you that something has gone
wrong here you've tried to assign to the
value zero well that's because you've
passed through zero as the thing that
you're attaching your your interface to
how to avoid this well in this case it's
fairly simple
we have attributes in the Wolfram
language that prevent this premature
evaluation of variables of expressions
in this case we just say well whenever
an expression gets passed to display to
this function that we've named display
in any argument make sure it doesn't
evaluate and in this case that's
sufficient so now we have I'm going to
without doing anything else without
changing the the display function in any
other way just setting this attribute is
enough to get the variable passed by
reference rather than by value so this
is a very common mistake for people that
are generating interfaces and if you
have utilities that are based on other
utilities and the chain along you'll
need to hold the variables at every step
if at the endpoint they are going to
want to change the value of that
variable in some interactive way
question
yes dynamic is holdall and dynamic up so
did it let me it's happening at the call
to display so if we do let me simulate
this so f a B let's say a is 1 B is to
hold of F of a B does not allow this to
evaluate but then we say we say what
well this is perhaps this is not the
best okay so so I don't know if people
in the back can hear what's going on
here the question the first question is
can you explain exactly why a and var
are leaking here because they seem to be
wrapped in a holding construct and then
there was another a follow-up suggestion
that we wrap a and var individually in
in expressions that have their own
holding attributes to prevent them from
evaluating both of those are valid
points in fact if you had the notebook
in front of you and you open the bonus
section you might see you might see a
reference to one of those but yes the
evaluation leak comes from evaluating
display of a comma var right I'm not
even going to try to simulate it it's
coming from from evaluating that inside
of dynamic yes because dynamic
translates to dynamic box of two boxes
of this thing and two boxes of display
and this is this is going to allow a and
var to evaluate yeah okay again bonus
section yours for later okay so that's
one common difficulty I'm going to show
you now a common pattern that we
invented for manipulate and we've used
it became so useful that I think we've
used it in just about every interface
since and that's the sense of versioning
the utility from
that generates the interface boxes so
here I have a another very simple
example I guess it's the same simple
example with a different name so we have
a function that creates an interface
it's a very simple interface it has hold
all but you'll notice that I added a
first argument don't really care the
structure of how you have this argument
but the important thing is that I have
some way of knowing that this is a
particular version of this utility this
is version 1 of this utility has nothing
to do with the mathematical version and
so the thing that gets burned into the
notebook for this interface knows that
it is version 1 of this utility if we
were to look at the boxes as a call to
this utility function version 1 why is
that important it seems sort of silly
but it does allow us to do some really
nice things for one thing it allows us
to in a targeted way update a particular
calling signature for the utility to do
something different so say we learned
you know day 1 of summer school we
learned about label slider and we're
really happy with ourselves then day 2
we learned about 2d layout constructs
and styling constructs and we wanted to
update all of our interfaces to take
advantage of those well if we update the
definition of this down value then as
soon as I evaluate this input that
previous output is going to change
automatically so we can in a targeted
way update the down value for just a
particular rendering of the boxes
it also lets us cleanly say well now I
have a brand-new version of the box
generating function and I want to do
something completely different because I
know about some new box because I've
learned something new about the front
end or the kernel and I'm going to do
something fundamentally different I
don't want the new interfaces to come to
conflict with the old ones so the thing
so I've learned about some new controls
now and I burn this into notebooks it's
the same function but a new version
number why not just use a new function
well the one nice way one nice thing
about keeping these all in the same
attach the same function is that we can
do the following say I have a newer
version of the front end a newer version
of my code generates a newer version of
the output boxes Version three I send it
to my users my users don't yet have my
new code what should that look like for
them well I can't give them Version
three but I can set up their version one
of my package so that it does something
nice and clean when they get version
three boxes that their code otherwise
doesn't know about so we can have as
part of you know the very first
iteration of this you have a catch-all
for this for this function that says you
know I've gone through and I've tried
all of these and I don't have the write
down value for displaying this version
and you can say that in the interface so
here is here is you know the fall
through version that your users would
see and we actually do this I don't has
anybody ever seen something like this in
Mathematica proper because we do it for
manipulate we do it for interval slider
curious to know if anybody's ever
noticed this but okay so so we have
bumped version numbers in manipulate we
haven't bumped them for interval slider
yet so maybe that's not quite so
surprising but nobody's seen those but
it's interesting that nobody seen the
manipulate one so if if the manipulate
boxes were generated by a newer kernel
and then try to open in an ancient
front-end of some sort you might you
might see something like this okay
so this is this is backwards proofing
and forwards proofing your box
structures I think this is this is a
really nice approach okay
what else can I say about this so we get
a lot just by using dynamic just by
having a dynamic of a function that
generates these things we get a lot of
stuff for free because the the
construction of those boxes is delayed
that means anything that looks for
front-end options anything that looks
for kernel state all of that stuff is
delayed until render time each time you
open the notebook you get a fresh
you get a fresh look at what the front
end and Colonel look like and that can
affect how the boxes look so for
instance there's a front end option
default control placement this was
developed back before we had iOS support
but we were starting to look at
touchscreen devices running the desktop
front end and we realized that controls
on the top your hand is in the way of
the thing that you're trying to control
so we needed some automatic way to
change so without changing the boxes of
manipulate at all this is just
responding to the user state because the
user had set some option that that says
okay now every manipulate that gets
rendered from here on out for the
remainder of this session will look like
this if you save this send it to your
friend your cousin who doesn't have this
setting it will look normal it will look
like the slider only on the top you know
this is this is dependent on the the
state of your front end okay and I think
this is my last real slide so I want to
talk a little bit about loading your
code because there's a question about
you know you have a dynamic call to a
function that generates the interface
how do you make sure that that function
that generates the interface is actually
present and all of your code is actually
loaded so I'm going to show a couple of
techniques surrounding this question one
is to acknowledge that that dynamic
could do more than just call a single
function it could have a small amount of
logic in it that detects whether your
code is loaded or not and displays one
thing or something else depending on the
answer to is your code loaded so so here
is an interface that looks like one
thing looks like a button if the code is
not loaded and after the code is loaded
so it looks like something else of
course these are just small academic
displays you can get arbitrarily fancy
with their with their look if you happen
to know things about declare package and
stub files you should make sure that the
function that generates the interface is
one of those Auto loaded symbols it is
one of those that you declare the
package for so that it can
the process of loading your code
automatically and if you want to use the
initialization that's fine here is a
setup that I'm showing you how to use an
asynchronous initialization along with
the synchronous dynamic to do the
following it showed it automatically
loads this code while it's running and
doesn't provide the interface until the
code is completed so I'll run this third
time while the initialization is running
we see a please wait state when it's
done it's in a ready state and again you
can get arbitrarily clever with this
please wait state I think this one uses
a percolator to give the user something
to watch while while your code is
running and this is how it manipulates
synchronous initialization option works
for instance for those of you who hasn't
who haven't seen that in action it
provides an indeterminate progress
indicator while asynchronous
initializations are happening and that's
exactly it uses exactly this technique
but be aware that when you're
initializing and when you have dynamic
variables running around you do want
those to play nicely with one another
you should think carefully if you're
developing one of these interfaces think
carefully about what would happen if you
had two of them on-screen at the same
time if they're both trying to set
global state they may well get into a
tennis match and you'll see you sell
brackets flashing and you'll you'll find
that typing becomes unresponsive so it
is it is some additional thought needs
to go into what should multiple
interfaces do while they're open at the
same time so initialize responsibly
right okay so and the rest are bonus
slides I've covered just about
everything I wanted to cover main
takeaways simplify what gets written
into notebook files store this used
dynamic module to store the state use
dynamic to to create the interface boxes
at render time use dynamic also to
respond to environment changes and
use this nice utility versioning to
support forward backward compatibility
and using all of these approaches you
can ensure a great experience for your
past present and future uses so thanks
for your attention I think we have time
for some questions yes the comment is if
you use manipulate you don't have to do
anything else to get these these
benefits and yes that's true if
manipulate is sufficient for you or for
your users then there's no need for you
to reinvent any wheels but this this was
the approach we took with manipulate and
again with interval slider and audio and
Wolfram Alpha function and a few other
things and right so so as you develop
your own interfaces this is this is the
this is this is the the these are
signposts on that trail for you to
follow yes
yep the question is could there be
unintended side-effects from setting the
hold all attribute for a symbol and
absolutely there could be if in this
case since you are the one that's in
control of writing the boxes of
constructing the call to this utility
and you're the one that's writing the
definition of the utility all of these
things are in your lap to take care of
but absolutely I mean if if you expect
for instance what you could not do in
this case
after you set hold all you would no
longer be able to do something like add
a down value whose left hand side
matched you know a partially evaluated
symbol because and because of the hold
all attribute you would never see
display will never see zero here it will
only see a variable given the way that
we're calling it up there so yes there
there is there is the potential for a
fall out if and as you as you do a
couple of these you you'll you'll get
accustomed to what that might look like
okay well enjoy the rest of the
conference and the pizza and I'll hang
out here for a few minutes because I
think the room is now finished if people
have other questions so thanks
[Applause]